nice we're also very excited we've got
big news this morning because our next
guest is singer-songwriter john legend
i adore this man he's on a mission to
encourage everybody to get the
coronavirus vaccine
more than 96 million people in this
country have been fully vaccinated but
that's only about 30 percent of the
population
the 12-time grammy winner yep 12 times
teamed up with walgreens earlier this
month to help build trust in the vaccine
and to reach communities that are hit
the hardest by the pandemic today
exclusively on cbs this morning we thank
you for that john he's sharing a video
of the moment he got his vaccine at
walgreens here's a look
all right you might feel a little pinch
okay okay
that's a little pinch
guys this is our shot i got the kova 19
vaccine today
i'm feeling good and you're looking good
too john legend joins us
only on cbs this morning good morning to
you john did you hear kirby's having a
baby
i am so excited for you gail
congratulations
we have our kids grandmother living with
us uh
pepper christie's mother what do they
call her what yeah what are they calling
you call her
that's a tie for grandma um then
uh my mother they call grandma grandma
stevens
and um we called my grandmother's
grandma
and granny so i feel like those are
titles you will reject
i definitely don't want to be granny you
know something about writing songs so
maybe you'll come up with a name for me
i would
but that's not why we're here to talk
about kirby's baby we're here to talk
about you and your campaign
to get the people vaccinated in the
hardest hit because i tell you john when
i got my vaccine i wanted to weep
because i felt such a sense of
anthony we were all time we've all been
vaccinated here at the table
and you just feel such a sense of relief
and i don't you don't even know how
relieved you feel until you get it
but still there are a lot of people who
are scared and they're very skeptical
so what are you saying what are you
doing to convince them
well i feel relieved as well and i've
seen
the devastation the separation caused by
the cove
19 vaccine normally we would have gone
home
to ohio for the holidays either
thanksgiving or christmas
every year we weren't able to do that
this year we did christmas on
zoom i want to get back with my family i
want to see my older family members and
not
fear for their health and their safety
and it really is relieving
to have this vaccine to know that my uh
parents are getting it my older family
members are getting it
my wife got it uh my mother-in-law got
it
to know that they're all getting it and
we can all safely get back together
again it's really relieving it's really
exciting
it means that uh a lot of this
devastation and destruction and and
separation that we've seen over the past
year is is almost over
i know i'm with you on that john but you
know there have been hiccups with the j
j vaccine people think it was too rushed
people think maybe it's not safe and
quite frankly they're just terrified
they're just terrified
how do you help people not be so scared
yeah i balance
i balance the risk if you think about
the risks
that you'll take by actually getting the
virus we've seen
over 500 000 people lose their lives in
the us
in the past year we see the devastation
that is wreaking in
india right now where the hospitals are
overflowing and they
they they are losing so many people it's
so devastating
to actually get the covet 19 virus
and the vaccine is infinitesimally
risky compared to actually getting the
virus itself
so i think uh when you compare the risk
of getting it versus
the the tiny risks that we've seen with
the vaccine itself i think
it's a clear decision for me and it was
for me personally and
i encourage my family to do it and uh i
encourage everybody in the country to do
it
yeah it's it's totally worth it and i
mean and like you john my my whole
family has just
just finally gotten vaccinated we went
out to our first family dinner last
night
outside which just felt so nice and but
but did you
you've had the second shot right did you
get a kick from it in any way of a
reaction
i didn't but i've had family members
that have and it's one of the the
symptoms that some people do get
temporary though that
that discomfort it's so temporary my
brother got it he said it lasted about a
day he felt
kind of flu symptoms my uncle uh also
felt some flu symptoms for a day
again uh the if you compare that to the
pain people feel when they actually
contract the covet 19 virus
it is minimal but uh it is a symptom
that some people are getting
yeah but as as as any doctor will tell
you it's also a sign that that the
vaccine is working
that's the point yeah your body's your
body's working your immune system is
rallying for you all right john we're
going to take a break i know you got up
early in los
angeles if you could just stay with us a
little bit longer we want to take a
break and come back to talk about your
graduation speech to the duke grads and
to see how you and chrissy are doing
we are back now with john legend who is
pushing everybody to get vaccinated
in part so people like him and all of us
can enjoy live
music again wouldn't that be nice but
john i actually want to start
with a different live event you're going
to be giving the commencement address
to duke university graduates this coming
sunday
i love commencement addresses some of
the best speeches of the past 20 years
are done at graduations what do you plan
on
delivering what do you plan on telling
the graduates well
i love giving commencement speeches and
it's interesting that you mentioned that
we haven't had concerts
i literally have not been in front of an
audience
for over a year and this will be my
first time
in front of any sort of audience since
the pandemic started so i'm excited to
go to duke
i'm excited to speak to the class of
2021 they've been through a tough year a
different year than
most students will go through but i'm
excited to
uh encourage them to go out and try to
make the world a better place
so have you begun writing it i mean if
you got it
you've been uh rehearsing it uh you know
i've been writing it
i've been rehearsing it we're trying to
cut it down a little bit because it's a
little long right now
but i'm really excited to talk to them
and spend some time in durham i have
some family there so i'm gonna have a
nice time
in north carolina and again i haven't
done anything in public
for over a year so it's really exciting
for me to just go ahead and do that
yeah i know will you sing a note or two
or will you just stand there because
number one
people know this john legend is scary
smart
so i think you know he wrote an essay
when he was 14 15 years old he's
super super smart so will you sing a
note or two to the graduates
i'm sure they're glad you're coming but
i may bust out a quick song
if it feels relevant to what i'm saying
we'll figure it out well there's so much
going on in the country now john you
know the big story last week was of
course the derek chovan verdict
i want to get your thoughts on that and
where we are as a country today
what did you think when you heard the
verdict many people were afraid to hope
that
that
would be the outcome i was afraid to
hope that as well you know we've seen
so many times where even with video
evidence
even with lots of eyewitnesses we
haven't seen any sort of accountability
for officers when they use the power of
the state
to kill someone and finally we saw
some level of accountability that
doesn't mean systemic change that
doesn't mean we solve the problem
but it does mean this one officer who on
video
uh so callously murdered george floyd
will have some accountability and
i that's better than it not happening
for sure but it doesn't mean that our
work is done
yeah we were also listen i love anytime
you and chrissy post pictures of miles
and luna because they really are little
mini me's
they really are there's no question that
john legend is a father of these
children
i mean they are such they are such many
memes so i love that you guys share your
life i was also so touched when you all
shared the
the loss of your son when chrissy had
the miscarriage and you got such a huge
outpouring of support number one i was
so glad that you shared it i know
chrissy said that you were reluctant at
first
to share it um what did the public
support mean to
you and why were you apprehensive in the
beginning
well you know chrissy always is more
sharing than i am i'm a bit more private
but
what i learned through that process was
first of all how
often this happens to so many other
families around the world
and we felt a real sense of community by
sharing it with other people
and they felt seen by us we felt seen by
them
and i think it helps everyone deal with
their grief when they know that there
are other people out there
who are feeling it and so i am so glad
chrissy's instinct was to share this
because it was really the right thing to
do and uh it helped us get through it
and i think it helped other families who
are going through the same thing
get through it yeah more than that john
i think it was really important that you
did it
having been through it in our family i
know i know what it meant
to have it talked about publicly because
it's so often it's not it's kept in the
shadows and
i absolutely i really appreciate that
yeah people feel such shame and
and they feel lonely and i think we
helped people feel less lonely yeah you
absolutely did
i when you mentioned this the duke
speech being your first appearance in
front of an audience
uh in in a year have you contemplated
getting back on the road and touring
what does that look like for you down
the road
oh i'm so excited to do it and it's
another selfish reason why
i want everyone to get vaccinated
because that's really our ticket to
getting back together is
to uh increase the immunity in the
community so that
we can safely get back together in large
crowds and
and not just selfishly for me though but
if you think about the entire
arts industry there are so many
performers
so many crew people production people
who have been out of work
uh for a long time now and uh
arts adds so much to our community it's
not selfish the audience wants you back
too
yeah we sure do we want you back it's
it's good for the soul john legend thank
you so much for being with us
we really appreciate it we'll come see
you when you come back we sure will
we'll be there
we'll be right back
you're watching cbs this morning
[Music]
donors